I got a few cousins that know their
gloutch esters from their Glouster x' so
I think I can do this
Billerica it sounds like someone's name
villarica it is an alternate name for
America is the double elf pronounced
like a whi like in Spanish pietà Rica
how else can you possibly pronounce this
bill Ricca then where there's an either
that everyone's forgetting about I like
it better as the lair I got more
patriotic Gloster like there should be
an H in here and then I would know how
to say a twister glob Chester flower
sister glow Chester Glouster next it's
glossy ice that's sinful coach it shoe
it
this one is really hard what Coach eat
watch a dr. OTT II consistory the
concert week over the curse word coach
it's Wow
are they just trying to trick you
Leominster leo Minster Wow mints that we
all Minster lemon sir Leominster
what the hell up into the Oh Lester what
the hell there's too many E's in this
word leister my sister least ER less
sister I don't even know what sounds
letters make anymore Lester yeah nailed
it hold up a second I know someone named
Lester and that's not how it's spelled
them why even have all these letters if
you're not gonna use the Massachusetts
Haverhill
I would say Haverhill but by my
knowledge of today it's probably like
it's probably just pronounced tail
Tauber he'll have her he'll how do you
mispronounce that
Haverhill it's pain every letter for the
sound that the dictionary gives it have
a hill
Haverhill Harry Potter Hill Hibbert um
Avril Haverhill oh my god not a real
word either pronounce them the way
they're written or write them
differently Massachusetts Worcester this
one I know because it's like the sauce
right we're sisters work for sure sir
sauce war sister werster wall sister
Lester
yeah what sir let's ignore ours and get
less a more seasoned ease - this is why
the rest of America doesn't like to hang
out with you
I'm never going to Massachusetts I just
don't know how anyone ever knows where
they're going because if someone was
like go - were sure what what is it
Worcester I would like look on the map
for five hours and be like this isn't a
place like I'm going home you know did I
do my family proud today
no I did not but ah Go Red Sox